sa vie
je vais essayer de répondre à la
présentation
après tout c'est
nous demander
si
personnellement des andonces depuis le
derby à stabiliser
le preneur le pourquoi le succès autre
chose donc
je reviens de loin commentant des
affiches
on commence à ranger type précis définis
révéré en russie qui doivent être
identifiables
et sous réalistes que
nous
il faut se poser cette question et
notamment c'est notre jeu suivant des
conditions est par le fond le gravit
courte est ce que je veux
sur six mois
de décembre les sons de temps
et la réussite qui vient après pour
tenir ses objectifs
je pense que chacun de nous est aspiré
par un modèle un exemple personne à
la personne
c'est en s'y par le la fin de citation
ses nerfs et laissez vos
lecteurs cd on savait pour réaliser des
jours
quelqu'un qui a causé je pense que s'ils
vont se rendre ensemble pour voir des
chercheurs message des scientifiques ils
ont poussé les mêmes sources aux
claviers
impossible mais quand même si on voit un
peu plus de fait ce qu'ils ont fait
c'est qu'ils ont osé suivre leur
intuition 9e rue pour réaliser beaucoup
deux des gens c'est qu'on connait tout
ornement pourri tellement bon
curieux
et dépassant les limites achats dans
votre vie ne vous comptez pas sur chez
nous faisait de cocody est l'exemple
juste par exemple je me rappelais âge de
10 ans
chris faire des exploits
allez chercher vos deux montages
financiers
j'ai décortiqué avertissent les coupes
pour découvrir les paris
pour des emplois
et par la suite il devient question les
fidji je dois me romani est-ce que de
rêver
je dis que c'est pas cependant de rêve
il faut rêver planifié a t il ajouté
c'est la persévérance
qualité de ceux qui persévèrent dans ce
qu'elle entreprend quelle que soit sa
religion c'est une couche de principal
est toujours des obstacles surmontés
et
cette chaîne
que pour l'histoire je
vire a le
droit au sein de membres donc voilà j'ai
en tout il ya celui ressenti
donc on va je me suis dit je crois
devant mes yeux je vais vraiment ballon
d'ailleurs pour faire des études mais
on a décidé et je n'ai pas
pourquoi c'était vraiment un champ
réduit en rien voulez voyager pour tous
les goûts et pour le réaliser dans saint
pierre mais puisque effectivement je
devais baisser les bras
voilà mon rêve c'était un but
la question des changes
aujourd'hui je ne sais pas si
je rejoins tenu à s'y arrêter pour
continuer à chercher
des gens qui font le site universitaire
qui touche les modèles julien ça veut
dire mais vous savez qu il faut pour
s'arrêter seule trajectoire bon j'ai
fait je devais faire je devais
poursuivre à chercher c'est que le sujet
d'un départ imminent les appareils sur
soi comment faire ailleurs plusieurs
nations se résume pas déjà
avoir une attitude positive
cherché toute force intérieure qui vous
même pour faire votre défi vert le raid
surprise
laissé ses jambes côté ils sont près des
bassins qui stimule votre motivation
vous aider
et pour cela je dirai la vérité de
l'histoire y a pas atteint ce chemin y'a
pas se mêler des halles le fréchou et
celui contraste avec le groupe pro - le
propres compétences et en tant
qu'exemple aujourd'hui c'est vrai
j'y pense et la réussite une recette
bien plusieurs dégâts et chacun déploie
les électeurs qu'il veut en deux jours
sorti un disque en main ce qu'on appelle
le sérieux type dans la société
celle-ci vos propres moyens vous avez
déployés
pour
avoir l'ambition
l'ambition
c'est une
force intérieure qui sera
ambitieux il faut que le sens du
leadership
aller avant nous montrer du concret et
nous et surtout sur tout seul surtout à
se
poser des questions touchant décidément
quel point de distinguer une question
simple il le monde le plus de vos rangs
des ces deux visites dans des
destinations qui dit des oui
on concevoir danseuse d'ivoire
s'est par la suite à tous les jours de
congés pour soins de remanier jeudi
on n'est pas au rendez vous mais je dois
tirer parce que
ce n'est pas vrai donc
quelques années après
je me demande encore et déçu
c'est une
masure apprentissage
c'est cette fois raccroche aux
deux jours et c'est lent je vais faire
est lié encore
pour renforcer les compétences
matérielles pour avoir un on va s'y
dérouler
c'est toujours pour cette soir que je
continue mais en parallèle je devais un
sentiment un besoin à cet hiver un
besoin qui
s'articule en fait par rapport à des
points faute et
je vous invite à lire ce que j'ai appris
et je dois partager j'ai acquis à lait
des autres c'est ça la vie parce qu'on
est
dans une société où bien des gens
et détruit
plusieurs mois
l'initiation dont on travaille sous
sédatifs
j'ai choisi un on va dire franchement
c'était à 2,6 puis parce que je voulais
faire deux choses
et
de paris
où
étaient rassemblés
les âges si c'est de joindre aucune
action à laquelle je lui participé à une
dizaine
le grand h
moi j'étais bien des parties de faire
partie du comité organisateur
sur les 2500 fin de cdd courts qui font
une marche des dames ont fui
et bien sûr le petit fille dans le but
de financer délicieuse du cp
construction d'un centre de formation et
l j
shadow war du sexe dans l'agent de
l'huile est donc ce vécu à partir et à
travers de ce
qui ressemble beaucoup de gens qui
devient beaucoup plus intéressant
ou esprit qu on y trouve le nez le
challenge est en
réalité c'est sûr si on doit beaucoup de
choses
le premier paiement bien sûr ce n'était
que le début parce que je devais
continuer à renforcer enchères ce besoin
personnel depuis des années on a les
faisais des activités on retient le
juger car ces mamans ses députations ont
joué
ce sujet en disant que chaque année les
initiatives pour
collecter et
commissaires scolaires aux élèves des
prix en début de visite parce que moi je
considère que
mon qui ont la chance
qui a la chance d'aller à l'école
vraiment pas cette chance et pourquoi vu
ses chances
ces deux
potentiels ils arrivent peut quitter
montréal
cécile des écoles puissent s y
consacriez deux ans qui est là le la
bibliothèque c'est simon faveur de plus
canada et le village et les aider ou les
petits-enfants un livre marie sûr
c'était une chance
pour nos sociétés c'est quelque chose
qu'on doit toujours conservé avec nos
enfants arrêtent le voir le petit cousin
dans deux ans un des faucons ça et puis
aussi un petit effort pour encourager
les locataires
je dirais
je dirais qu à travers ce travail
collectif et c'est pareil il faut juste
accroché aux opportunités je n'ai pas
s'accrocher aux grandes opportunités et
petite remontée se présente parce que
paraît le traitement et vont devenir et
la
liste pour susciter soyez une agent de
changement je n'ai pensé c'est de
réfléchir à chaque fois rappelé à
court de forme et ce ne sont que parce
que je dois expliquer où chaque fois je
peux exploiter à
on ne dit rien
j'ai toujours cette soif de chercher
et c'est l'orgie par thiem fait à
chercher pourquoi est ce qu'il ya
vraiment des grands de béton et ciment
je trouvais info cran de main d'oeuvre
est
initialement les femmes qui travaillent
dans les technologies dans les jambes et
mes deux listes
oui dit et je cite l'algérie la vidéo
donc la mission qui se posent et
choisir si favre pour présenter les
états unis est ce que je peux faire
partie de cette équipe de seconde si
celui-ci g ok je suis dit
il faut prendre au port je leur ai dit
ce changement dans la société pourquoi
pas vous g2j si généralisée pourquoi est
il si bon j'ai créé en mai j'ai pu la
réaliser et c'est dans ce cadre que je
suis parti à les voir toutes les entrées
des grandes heures
des
biens achetés dans les universités
telles que
je n'ai jamais vu
combien je commencerai à diriger et une
expérience il
ce que personnel pour moi ce processus
la plupart des compacts
rassembler un jour
créer des réseaux sociaux mais lui
sait pas aller sous l'eau et des
entreprises qui regroupe alors on va
dire
qu'il emploie
est quand même cédé sens que j'ai pu et
je
te prends l'exemple de cette société et
d'un seul coup tout est friand
participer à ce programme j'ai compris
une chose il est pas quelque chose qu'on
doit leur vie je crois qu'un américain
du succès mérité on
poussait
deschamps qui peut laisser penser qu'ils
font et ce qu'ils le monde
bur ans
s'était parée de lâcher prise
n'hésitez pas et moi croyez moi qui
menacent yeux parce qu'en faisant ça
nous allait arriver à régler les jours
marie
c'est le chant
donc soyez cet agent de changement dans
notre société ne dit jamais c'est un
petit changement ces deux changements
sains dans votre panier encourage
milieu un certain
regard ce qui a partagé des
11 et c'est parce que si vous n'osez pas
vous dépassez pas maigri brosser dans le
sens bien et je pense que vous avez
laissé pour mort dans le stéréotype
les stéréotypes chacun une expérience
unique chacun d'un mot à dire chacun
d'eux en sorte que chacun puisse
partager ces éléments avec les essieux
congédie à poser des questions pour la
vision qu'elle consommait une question
simple question
je terminerai aussi en dix ans
ddd plus grands singes français
étaient vialli et pour le groupement
durant toute sa vie il m'a
personnellement je considère qu'il est
on est en mouvement est aussi rappelée
âmes en jeu jusqu'à cet exemple juste
venir
marquer aux contours
fêter tous les seniors 1 c'est super
important parce que si vous voulez faire
il ya une profession qui vont pas
nous aura raison vous êtes l'exemple
vous avez des jeunes qui vont pouvoir
les choses de bon question est agrégé
remis pour quelques années mercy le
brochet impliqué e dans kitsch
et
chez
ceux ci fléché